my research has really affected my
understanding of my own identity in a
number of different ways you know at the
most conscious level thanks largely to
the work in the successful societies
program we've actually looked at the
capacity of people to maintain multiple
identities right and come to understand
that most people do have multiple
identities and can maintain them without
conflict so at that level I've got that
and so I'm comfortable with my own
notions of my multiple identities at the
level that I've been talking at in the
presentation though what I've come to be
able to do is to be able in my own mind
to separate out things that are
biological driving capacities that are
deeply embedded in me but I don't
necessarily want to take account of
versus things that aren't so I feel like
I've developed a little bit of what the
Dalai Lama has the capacity to stand
outside of one's drives and actually say
you know is this something I'm going to
respond to or not so for me you know
there is something there about the I
beam having the identity of a conscious
person that really emerges from that